So in this video, I'm going to give you some tips or a tip on how you can improve your
wind rate with ABC trading strategy, okay?
So let's assume that you have a POI, right?
It could be an auto block or a fair value gap on a higher timeframe.
And you can also take this into consideration that you had a, you know, a lower low, lower
high, and then you had a market structure break or break of structure, right?
So usually when you are trading smart money or auto flow trading strategy, you would take
your entry from this level.
However, if you want to increase your ABC strategy win rate, what you can do is look for
an ABC pattern near your POI and the C leg goes into your POI like this.
So we have an ABC and the C leg goes into your POI.
Now that is going to increase your wind rate tremendously, okay?
Not tremendously, but it's going to give like a 5% or 10% increase to your wind rate.
So you are going to then follow the rules again, right?
As I have taught the ABC strategy, you then wait for a market structure shift with displacement,
with volume, and then you take your entry from the extreme fairly gap and kaboom.
So this is something that you can take into consideration, all right?
What you want to do is you want to identify a POI.
It could be an auto block.
It could be a fair value gap, a high timeframe, right?
And then you wait for price to give you an ABC pattern near your POI and the C leg goes
into the POI, right?
And when it does, then you can look for a market structure shift within the range, which
is here, right?
So if the price breaks a structure somewhere around here, you look for your entry and boom.
Trust me, it's going to increase your wind rate by 10 to even 15%.
So yeah, I hope you liked this tip and let's move on to the next video.